Keith olberman responded saying sure
it's suspect because your side and Libs
of tick tock got caught inspiring a mass
murderer blood on your hands Fu and I
said I really don't care what the cult
thinks like at all fart fart Keith
olberman I'd say you're dumb as a box of
rocks but that's a demeaning to rocks
like I I just do I care about what
ranting raving lunatic Keith Olbermann
thinks he thought he thought Donald
Trump was it was a Russian spy like
these people are not smart people and
there's nothing like you know uh they
try to shame you and I'm just like I you
know I you can't shame me well your
booze mean nothing I've seen what makes
you cheer exactly I mean for for any
story especially if it's something that
suits their narrative you really need to
see hard proof from them in order to
give it any level of credibility well I
just don't care Keith olberman could
come out and be like look at this
picture of a thing happening and I just
laugh at him like you are a really dumb
guy and your words are meaningless and
there's no reason for me to read them
like there is nothing Keith olberman can
say that will impact my life in any
meaningful way